WATCHED ANY INTERVIEWS WITH THE
WOMAN ACCUSING HIM OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
>> Bret:
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS
BEEN A LIGHTNING ROD IN HER
FIRST CONGRESSIONAL TERM.
NEW YORKERS HAVE ARE FACING A
FORMIDABLE FORMER DEMOCRAT AND
FORMER REPUBLICAN.
CORRESPONDENT JACQUI HEINRICH
SHOWS US TO MATCH UP THIS
EVENING.
>> THE QUEENS CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ESTIMATED NEARLY HALF
OF THE NEIGHBORHOOD 6,000
RESTAURANTS MAY NOT SURVIVE THE
CURRENT ARREST PANDEMIC.
AND ONE WOMAN VYING FOR THE
DISTRICT’S CONGRESSIONAL SEAT IS
REMINDING VOTERS THE INCUMBENT,
CONGRESSWOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ LED THE
CHARGE AGAINST WHAT COULD HAVE
BEEN A MAJOR JOB MAKER.
>> WHEN SHE THREW 25,000 JOBS
OUT I THOUGHT, WOW, SHE HAS NO
IDEA HOW IMPORTANT JOBS ARE.
>> MICHELLE CABRERA, A FORMER
NEWS ANCHOR IS BILLING HERSELF
AS A BUSINESS FRIENDLY CENTRIST.
>> WE DEMOCRATS MADE CLEAR IN
THE PRIMARIES WHAT WE WANTED.
WE WANT TO THE FAR LEFT, AND IF
WE WANT TO THE FAR LEFT WE WOULD
HAVE ONE.
>> THEY CRITICIZED THE AOC FOR
THE CURRENT AFFAIRS TO LEAVE
BILL SAYING SHE’S OUT OF TOUCH
WITH HER’S CONSTITUENTS.
>> AT THE HEIGHT OF THE CRISIS
AOC STATED HER LUXURY APARTMENT,
AND SHE DIDN’T COME HOME EVEN
THOUGH PEOPLE WERE DYING.
>> SHE WANTS CALLED HERSELF A
WHOLE FOODS REPUBLICAN AND WAS
REGISTERED TO THE PARTY.
SHE ADVOCATED FOR SMALL
GOVERNMENT AND FISCAL
CONSERVATISM IN HER 2010 BOOK
WHICH INCLUDES A FORWARD BITE
TRUMP ECONOMIC ADVISOR
LARRY KUDLOW AND SHE ONLY MOVES
HOW MIKE MOVED TO QUEENS LAST
YEAR PREVIOUSLY LIVING IN A
MANHATTAN TRUMP BUILDING.
>> SHE DECIDED TO CHALLENGE ME
FOR THE SAKE OF CHALLENGING ME.
CABRERA’S CAMPAIGN IS GETTING
THE BACKING OF THE U.S. CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WHICH HAS POURED